The realization that pleasure could be
usefully for stole dawn with a
difficulty that's almost impossible to
overstate a realization runs absolutely
contrary to our ancient fundamental
animal instincts which demand immediate
satisfaction,
particularly under conditions of
deprivation,
which are both inevitable and
commonplace,
and to complicate the matter,
such delay only becomes useful when
civilization has stabilized itself
enough to guarantee the existence of the
delayed reward.
If everything you save will be destroyed
or worse,
stolen,
there's no point saving.
It's for this reason that a wolf will
down 20 pounds of raw meat in a single
meal.
He isn't thinking,
man,
I hate it when I binge.
I should save some of this for next
week.
Here's a developmental progression from
animal to human.
It's wrong,
no doubt in the details,
but it's sufficiently correct for our
purposes in theme.
First,
there's excess food.
Large carcasses.
Mammoths are other massive herbivores
might provide that way.
A lot of mammoth,
maybe all of them with a large animal.
There's some left for later after a
kill.
That's accidental at first,
but eventually the utility of for later
starts to be appreciated.
Some provisional notion of sacrifice
develops at the same time.
If I leave some now,
even if I want it now,
I won't have to be hungry later.
That provisional notion then develops to
the next level.
If I leave some for later,
I won't have to go hungry and neither
will those I care for and then to the
next level.
I can't possibly eat all this mammoth,
but I can't store the rest for too long
either.
Maybe I should feed some to other
people.
Maybe they'll remember and feed me some
of their mammoth when they have some and
I have none.
Then I'll get some mammoth now and some
mammoth later.
That's a good deal and maybe those I'm
sharing with will come to trust me more
generally.
Maybe then we could trade forever in
such a manner.
Mammoth becomes future,
mammoth and future.
Mammoth becomes personal reputation.
That's the emergence of the social
contract to share does not mean to give
away something you value and get nothing
back.
That's only instead what?
Every child who refuses to share his
afraid that it means to share means
properly to initiate the process of
trade.
A child who can't share,
who can't trade,
can't have any friends because having
friends is a form of trade.
Benjamin Franklin once suggested that a
newcomer to a neighborhood ask a new
neighbor to do him or her a favor citing
an old maxim.
He that has once done,
you have kindness,
will be more ready to do you another.
Then he whom you yourself have obliged
in Franklin,
so opinion.
Asking something for someone,
asking someone for something not too
extreme.